hello i'm greg sadler i am the
translator editor in a large respect
author
of large portions of this book
reason fulfilled by revelation
which discusses the 1930s philosophy
debates that took place in france
i'm going to talk in this section this
video about
the answer to a question that every
author should have handy i think all the
time
and that is
why should anyone want to read your book
what is so valuable in this this text
that i should go and get it and spend
the time reading through it
and i like to think of this in terms of
three sort of concentric circles
of of people one is very wide the the
general educated literate interested
public
another is a little bit more specialized
um
people in
the the fields broadly speaking of
religion
and then there's scholars and that's a
pretty small group and
as with a lot of book projects the
scholarly book projects this did not
start out as something that i thought
would have
very widespread general
interest
as a matter of fact i started
translating these documents and i'll
tell you the story about that in a
different video i started translating
these as sort of a
labor of love something that i was very
interested in doing myself
and i thought not too many other people
would be particularly interested and i
saw some great
implications for the the research that i
was i was doing
um
but
you know i thought it would be too
technical i thought that it might be a
little bit too abstract for for many
people
i was surprised as i've been talking and
doing presentations and people have been
asking me about the book and about the
the topics of christian philosophy just
how how much interest there is in in
this topic and how accessible
um
quite a lot of the the philosophy and
the discussions are as a matter of fact
one of the discussions that's in here
is a more popular discussion by by a guy
named bruno desolage
who was the director at the catholic
institute in toulouse
he was addressing the the
general public
and french philosophers quite a few of
them had an obligation to do so let me
put that aside though um
so
why would an ordinary
person who
has some interest in the life of the
mind be interested in in this book in
particular
well
um what this book makes available to you
are documents that were previously
untranslated that are part of a very
important debate about the nature of
christian philosophy whether it existed
whether it could possibly be rational so
if you're somebody
who is interested in
religion and modernity or
the relationship between reason and
faith or philosophy and christianity
then actually these debates are very
relevant to you
the issues that that are involved
in the very notion of christian
philosophy have never been examined
by as many people with as much depth and
as great detail
as they were during these debates
so
i think that really
if you're interested in
these great broad currents of ideas this
this is a book that you would like to
have and you would like to read
these uh these great philosophers who
were debating with each other in part
because
we often think of philosophers as being
in this ivory tower going off by
themselves but really the way that they
do their work is when they have
arguments with each other and they have
to
they have to respond to each other and
that's what was taking place during
these debates and that's part of what
hasn't been happening
at quite such a fever pitch
really since the 1930s so
that the book is well worth having just
for that alone so that you can see
what the various positions are that one
could take on these these
matters are
i think if you're somebody who's
historically inclined
my historical introduction and also some
of the discussions of the the
relationship between
philosophy
and history and some of the people that
are are discussed
historical figures as christian
philosophers as examples in in the
translations
you will probably find that very
interesting there's a real story to tell
there i don't tell the full story
uh in part because the book has to be
you know the documents and the
historical introduction is is you know
the historical introduction thematic
introduction are about 100 pages about
50 for the historical about 50 for the
thematic introduction
um and i am going to work on another
book i've already started
preliminary research on that which will
be an actual history of the debates
but
until that comes out if you're
interested in how did these debates take
place what was the historical context
why did french intellectual society
develop to such a point where it was
primed for a debate about christian
philosophy of all things to come to the
fore and be
the
cause celeb for about four years five
years of intellectual history well then
i think you'll want to read this book
um
i think that
now we're starting to to narrow the
circle
if you are somebody who
isn't necessarily a theologian or a
philosopher or a historian somebody
who's not a scholar full-time
uh
involved in teaching but you're somebody
who
is involved in some way with the
intellectual life of
a religious denomination
then you probably also want to know
about
the issue of christian philosophy
this is something that is
is core in
the tradition that i belong to the the
catholic tradition that's so important
actually that
that popes have written encyclicals
about it um
but it's also important in a lot of
protestant traditions it's very
important for
lutherans
for reformed christians
you see the wesleyans actually becoming
very interested in the conception of
christian philosophy in the last
15 years or so articles coming out about
that
i think evangelicals have a strong
interest in in this you know question
not necessarily about philosophy but
about reason rationality
is religion on the one hand and
rationality on the other do those merge
at all do they have confluences
or are they necessarily in conflict
are there models that we can find in
past philosophers whether in antiquity
in the patristic era in the middle ages
in the great you know scholastic or or
monastic
philosophers like anselm aquinas
bonaventure um or in later times uh you
know in the 19th century or in the 20th
century with some of these figures
blondel
marcel
jilson do they offer us models for for
christian philosophy
well i think if you are
a seminarian i think that if you are a
pastor i think that if you are
even somebody who is is involved in some
other kind of ministry
if it's any way involved with with
reason or intellectual life i think this
is a book that you probably would want
to read
i think it will be
fruitful for you uh the other groups
that i i think would be particularly
interested in so now we're narrowing yet
to an even smaller group are our
scholars
and i think that
philosophers theologians and historians
particularly historians of ideas would
be would be interested in this
and i i
in the book i actually talk about four
groups who i think would be particularly
interested one is is catholic
philosophers and theologians because
many of the figures writing in this
that i've translated are in fact
catholic thinkers
quite a few of whom actually are
mentioned in fides erazio
i think that
there
for a long time maurice blondel's voice
and those who are are closely aligned
with him like uh
uh antonin sertian and to a lesser
extent gabriel marcel have kind of
fallen silent
and part of what i tried to do by by
translating this was to restore their
voices in english so that not only would
we have
great works about christian philosophy
like atn joe sones spirit of medieval
philosophy a classic that i recommend to
everybody or jacques moore attends
an essay on christian philosophy but
we'd also have the some of the the works
of other figures who took part part in
those debates like like blown down like
marcel like certian
also we'd know more about the opponents
of christian philosophy i've translated
some of those
so again if you're a catholic
philosopher or theologian i think you'd
probably want to to
purchase this book
if you're a protestant
there are a lot of protestant
discussions now about christian
philosophy particularly among
reformed protestants but also among
evangelicals wesleyans
lutherans anglicans
all different types actually there's
even an essay out about a pentecostal
christian philosophy
why would you want this then well again
i think that
what's been lost is that
these issues
were never debated quite as as fiercely
as they were by these thinkers and it
wasn't just catholic thinkers actually
involved in the 1930s debates there
weren't just catholics
and rationalists as we would call them
now seculars there were actually some
reformed protestant thinkers
involved
jacques bois comes to mind pure garin
comes to mind notice these are all
french names these are not names that we
find
talked about a lot over over here
the other reason why i think
that protestants might find this very
interesting protestant scholars might
find it very interesting is there was
actually another set of debates that
took place roughly from about
1947 on through the 1950s
that were occasioned by
another book
um
by a guy named mel who
was responding to to the catholic
thinkers and the rationalist thinkers
in the debates
he wrote a book which was translated
into english and called the condition of
the christian philosopher
they had started another set of debates
among reformed protestants
french-speaking reformed protestants
including um
paul recur
who later on goes on to become a very
famous phenomenologist and hermeneutic
philosopher
he had his early
writings he was very interested in
christian philosophy
um
so yeah
catholic theologians and philosophers
reformed uh or other protestant uh
theologians and philosophers who also be
interested in this i think if you're
doing continental philosophy
one of the things that often gets left
out in what we call continental
philosophy is the fact that
there were many thinkers
and all these people were talking to
each other all the time constantly they
were interacting with each other
there are many thinkers involved in
these these debates who
qualify as continental philosophers like
like maurice blondell for example
blondel
had connections with mark schaeler he
had connections with heidegger through
anastograssi
there was a lot of interplay between
phenomenologists
and even marxists and catholic
tomists augustinians
maurice blondel of course uh there were
there was some overlap as well with
people like edith stein and gabriel
marcel where you had had christians who
were actually phenomenologists
so i think that if you want to
think of yourself as a well-read
continental philosopher if that's your
specialty
you want to know these debates you want
to know the figures who are involved in
these debates
the last group of scholars who i think
would probably benefit by by having
this book and reading through it
would be
people in the broader field of religious
studies or theology or philosophy of
religion so if you're doing those
sorts of
disciplines if you're involved in that
if that's what your formation is
this is important work i i'm not just
pushing it because i you know it's my my
book
it's actually in large respect not my
book
i wrote i wrote the introduction i
contextualized things historically and
thematically
i translated the documents but why did i
translate these documents
so i could take all of these great
thinkers and their voices and bring them
into
an english
idiom to to allow those who can't read
french and that's most of us
to
have access to this wealth of
thought
this brilliance that took place these
these great contests these great debates
that took place in the 1930s
and i think that if you're doing
philosophy of religion i think if you're
doing religious studies
you want to know this material